All right guys, so this is the chapter number two of the course of date in
This video in this topic. We are going to learn about the market maker by model and market maker
Cell model now. This is advanced market structure and if you can't identify this structure
Your win rate is gonna be like insanely crazy like 75 to 80 percent. I'm not even kidding
Now the reason why I don't trade this is
Because I'm a type of trader who want to be on the chart for like five to ten minutes max and just disappear, right?
So that's why I use the auto flow trading strategy. It's very easy. You just look for market structure shifts
But I can use these setups and make more money
But I don't I'm okay with two to three percent per month because I have funded accounts, right?
So I have three funded accounts. So if I'm making like two to three percent, that's enough for me
That is why I don't I don't use these methods. However, if you want to make more money
Or let's say you want to pause challenges lights instantly
The next few topics are gonna change your life and you have my work
So let's talk about market structure. Oh, sorry the market maker model the market maker cell model and the market maker by model
So let's assume that this right here is a key level, right? I have drawn this key level
Once price comes into your key level before you do anything
You have to look for this structure. So what is basically a market maker model?
So you have to identify a consolidation phase
Before price comes into your POI, right?
So there will be a consolidation a clean consolidation the very first consolidation before price comes into your POI, right?
You want to have a consolidation phase and then you can have another consolidation phase and another
Now these two consolidation phases are not necessary to see but you have to identify the main consolidation, right?
So let's say price is
Something like that, right? And then price consolidation consolidates a bit and you have like your high time frame level
Right there now you have to identify a clean
consolidation then price goes up now these
If you want to add these that that's gonna make like a very beautiful market market maker cell model
So even if you find like the second consolidation, you don't have to look for tight consolidation
However, I recommend you find at these two consolidation phases before price comes into your POI
So first consolidation and then a second consolidation, right?
And third one is not necessary
But if you if you see this then that's even better when price comes back into your POI you simply look for a market structure shift
so
Let's say price comes back here, right?
Into your POI you drop down to let's say you were looking at the daily time frame POI
So price comes into a daily POI you drop down to one hour time frame
And then on one hour time frame you look for this market maker cell model
Okay, wait, let me do this first
So I'm gonna repeat this again
You have your daily POI right price comes into your daily POI you drop down to the one hour time frame
Once you drop down to the one hour time frame, you want to identify a market maker model
which is basically a
consolidation original consolidation from where price consolidated and then starting moving up towards your POI and
If you see a pullback or a some sort of consolidation along the way, that is even better
Now once price comes into your POI you will look for a market structure shift on
one hour time frame now once you have a
Market structure shift on a one hour time frame
You can simply look to take your entry from the fairly gap, right or
What is a medication blog? Let's talk about medications blog. Then not that is the most important part of this thing, right?
So we have a buy curve here. So price was going up. That's why we call it a buy curve
Okay, a buy side curve. So it's it's like it's price is going up, right?
Now you have to mark out every single
Bullish autoblock right here. So let's say there was a bullish autoblock here, right?
And
There is a bullish autoblock here. We are going to utilize these autoblocks in our sell site curve
Okay, so since we have a market structure shift, we had the buy curve, right?
Now we're going to have the sell site curve. So we are going to use these autoblocks as our POIs. How?
Oh my god
So let's say price breaks through this autoblock, right?
And it creates a fairly gap or an autoblock inside this old
Bullish autoblock. Now that when that happens this become mitigated
Mitigation blog, okay, this becomes mitigation blog when price breaks through it. If it has to be able to gap you simply take your entry
Or if there's an autoblock inside here, you take your entry from the autoblock
Let's say price breaks this mitigation blog again. You have a mitigation blog right over here
And let's say there's a fairly gap formed inside the box or an autoblock
You take your entry from there and you keep shorting until this liquidity level is taken out. Oops my bad
Until this level, which is the original consolidation the low of the original consolidation is taken out
Now
Remember about the time from alignment, right? So for the daily
Daily bias and daily trading we go from day one to one hour and to five minute for a weekly
We go from weekly to four hour and then to 15 minutes, right?
For monthly we go from monthly to daily and then from daily to one hour. Remember that?
Okay, so
Let's remove let me remove this right here. Oops
Okay, so let me zoom in a bit
Once you get the market structure shift
right on the
One hour time frame now what you can do here is to increase
You know like your probabilities is
Inside this range right
inside this range here from
This low to this high you look for another market maker
Cell model. Okay, so for example when you drop down to the five-minute time frame
You will have to identify original consolidation around here
Right and then price goes back into your POI
Which would have been your entry on the one-hour time frame and then you simply target this low here on the five-minute
You look for the exact same setup. What is that?
consolidation another consolidation
not necessary but a
Plus point consolidation and you take your entry and you target this so I will give you guys a couple of examples then I'll end the video